Intro, Intro, Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Ufo, Intro, Intro, Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Ufo, Intro, Intro, Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Ufo, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Introin, troin, Tro, Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Ufo, Florentie Will und Stefan Tietz und so.
Hey, schön, dass ihr da seid. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge Das Podcast Ufo.
Vielen Dank an die das fantastische Intro an Lennart und Jano.
Entweder haben zwei Leute gesungen oder beide haben sehr ähnliche Stimmen, das ist immer schlecht in der Band.
Eine andere Stimme hört ihr jetzt allerdings. Es ist Stefan T. Wer soll es sonst sein? Er ist in der Haus!
Hey, ich freue mich sehr, hier zu sein. Dankeschön, dass auch ich mal zu Wort komme. Darauf, ich freue mich sehr, mit dir heute hier zu sein. Auch von mir. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur neuen Folge DPU das Podcast-Sofo. Schön, dass ihr da seid und ganz tolles Intro. Freut mich. Die Kreativität steigt. Skandal! Skandal, Skandal, Ausrufezeichen. Floh, die letzte Woche ein Intro zum zweiten Mal abgefeuert. Ist das der Schitzelmalarm oder was? Nein, die Intro-Polizei. Ja gut, eins von beiden. Sämtliche Alarme haben denselben Ton bei uns. Ähnliche Sirenen auf jeden Fall. Die Intro-Polizei kommt an und verpasst dir einen Strafzettel, denn so geht es nicht weiter, du hast zweimal Maximilian benutzt. Und da ist mir auch schon mal aufgefallen, dass du da ein bisschen schlampig mit umgehst und nicht klar kennzeichnest, wem wir schon mal hatten, dass es zum ersten Mal passiert, das ist das Einzige, was mich daran wundert. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, ich lasse nach, ich baue ab. Hast du das Gefühl, du baust? Ich steige ab, ja. Ich bin auf dem Abweg. Hast du das Gefühl, du baust geistig ab? Ich baue geistig ab, Werk abgerade, ich stolper so ein bisschen runter. Früher war ich hungrig, ich dachte, komm, die grossen Philosophen, die grossen Themen, ich arbeite mich hoch, ich hacke die Spitzhacke in den grossen Stein der Weisheit und ziehe mich hoch. Und heute reicht so leichtes Rauschen. Das reicht schon. So unaufdringliches Rauschen reicht völlig und ich bin zufrieden. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich war noch nie so fit im Kopf. An manchen Tagen, an die anderen Tagen denke ich mir, oh Gott, das reicht auch jetzt langsam. Reicht auch jetzt. Ich habe kein gutes Gedächtnis, das ist mir schon häufig aufgefallen. Ich habe für den Grossteil meiner, jetzt für die Serie musste ich wieder recherchieren, wann ist Abi, wie ist Abi. Ich habe keine Erinnerung an sowas wie Vor-Abi-Klausuren, keine Ahnung. Hatten wir eine Mensa, keine Ahnung. Ich habe keine Erinnerung an die Schulzeit. Aber wirklich so Dinge, Leute, wenn ich mich mit ehemaligen Schulkollegen zusammensetze und die noch so Geschichten erzählen von mir damals aus der Klasse.
Keine Erinnerung. Für mich ist das wie nie passiert, wie so ein Traum.
Hat jemand eine Geschichte erzählt und meinte,
da muss ich irgendwie so zwölf gewesen sein.
Ich dachte mir, bitte was?
Alter 25 und davor ist
Copy, äh,
Papierkorb öffnen,
Kontroll-V,
wiederherstellen, delete, für immer weg. Da ist nichts. Da ist nichts mehr. Und bei denen so, ja, als ich zweieinhalb Jahre war, da glaube ich, war ich vier Wochen alt oder so, ich glaube, da war Gorbatschow noch an der Macht, habe viele Dinge in der Macht. Ich weiß, es war Dienstag, war sonniger Tag, und ich lag da im Garten auf meinem Strampeltuch und hatte das Mobile gegenüber von mir und der Affe war kaputt, das weiß ich noch, weil es war, die ist da vor die Woche kaputt gegangen, wo man auch sagt, Leute, das funktioniert nicht, Lüge, Lüge, Lüge. Es ist unglaublich, ich hoffe, wenn ich irgendwie auf so einen Stand komme, das letzte Jahr noch so grob überblicken zu können, das wäre noch gut, aber ansonsten ist bei mir alles raus. Tagebuch,
sowas vielleicht?
Ich habe letztens noch mal reingelesen
in so ein Tagebuch, extrem
unangenehm, also
grössten Respekt an Menschen, die ihre Tagebücher
veröffentlichen, obwohl ich vermute,
dass sie oft ihre Tagebücher schon schreiben,
mit der Intention, es mal zu veröffentlichen.
Da habe ich letztens tatsächlich eine Gesprächsrunde
über den Ersten Weltkrieg gehört, wie vertraulich solche Tagebücher sind. Es gibt ja oft bei vielen historischen Epochen schlechte Quellen und gerade wenig Quellen von den Leuten, die sozusagen an der Front waren, sondern da gibt es die Generäle und die Politiker, aber die verklären ja alle so. Und dann denkt man sich, ja gut, dann schauen wir in die Tagebücher der Soldaten, die werden ja nicht lügen.
Aber dann ging es eben auch darum, dass die eben auch beschönigen und oft auch während des Kriegs ihr Tagebuch schreiben und sich denken, okay, da kann ich später was draus machen. Verrückt, dass die dann dachten, okay, da hole ich mir ein Buch oder sowas. Aber die eben das problematisiert haben, diese Tatsache. Und so denke ich mir auch, dass Leute, die ihr echtes Tagebuch schreiben, es niemals veröffentlicht werden, weil da nur Bullshit drinsteht, nur peinlicher Schwachsinn und auch da die Hälfte der Personen, die erwähnt werden, irgendwie grosse Liebe, ich werde sie ewig lieben, den Rest meines Lebens und heute denke ich mir so, Verena, was, Verena, keine Ahnung, ich kann es nicht mal lesen, so weit ist es weg von mir, überhaupt keine Ahnung. Aber auch gut zu sehen, dass die Probleme, die einen mal so beschäftigt haben,
auch einfach dahinfliegen.
Oder nicht.
Einfach abheben.
Die sind einfach weg.
Die steigen ins Auto und sind irgendwann in einem anderen Kontinent nur lebender.
Und man denkt sich, ach stimmt, da war mal was.
Aber es berührt mich nicht mehr. Also viele, ein Grossteil der Ratstärke, die man bekommt im Leben,
lassen sich eigentlich zusammenfassen zu fühlen nichts mehr. Oder warte so lange, bis das Problem nicht mehr so akut ist. Ja genau, also sowas wie, das wird schon alles, wenn jemand gestorben ist, das wird schon wieder. Oder wenn du jemanden liebst und die Person reagiert auf deine Gefühle nicht, ah du wirstirst schon drüber hinwegkommen, du wirst schon jemanden finden. Warte mal so drei, vier Jahre und dann scheint es nicht mehr so wichtig. Du wirst dich schon noch finden. Das ist immer, wenn man es runterbringt, fühl nichts, also vergiss, verdräng das Gefühl oder vergiss das Gefühl. Aber das ist aber auch vielleicht falsch, weil was wäre denn unser Leben ohne diese Probleme, die mal kommen und gehen, die uns ja auch shapen? Und diese Probleme, also ich meine, die grösartigen Kunstwerke sind aus einer Begierde entstanden oder aus einem Problem oder aus einem unerfüllten Traum. Ja. Und das ist doch vielleicht auch mal ganz gut, dass man sich, dass man fühlt. Ja, ich sage doch auch nichts, dass du nicht fühlen sollst. Aber du sagst, die Probleme fliegen hinweg und vielleicht sollte man die Probleme, da schwingt ihr ja mit, hast du es nicht gesagt, aber zwischen den Zeilen schwingt doch mit, Herr Will, dass man vielleicht nicht so sehr auf die Probleme achten sollte, sondern eher denken sollte, ja, das wird schon vergehen. Aber ist das Vergehen nicht das Problem? Ich würde diese Schwingung gerne zurücknehmen, das war ein Fehler, aber es gibt ja auch oft noch die anderen Ratschläge, die Leute, die genau Bescheid wissen. Also ich bin kein Fan von Ratschlägen. Generell, wirklich, ich gebe ungern Ratschläge, ich krieg ungern Ratschläge, weil ich es in meinem Leben noch nie erlebt habe, dass Ratschläge tatsächlich was gebracht haben. Ich gebe immer Ratschläge, also ungefragt auch teilweise, und die sind immer falsch. Aber Rchläge, glaube ich, sind auch es ist eine schwere, weil ich sehe oft Leute, die gefragt werden, so ja, keine Ahnung, ich bin jetzt irgendwie, ich trifft jetzt gerade in die Kriminalität ab, irgendwie, ich bin Drogenabhängig, ich habe kein Geld mehr, irgendwie meine Ex-Freundin ist weg, was soll ich machen? Und die dann allen Ernstes denen was sagen können, so wo ich mir denke, ja, keine Ahnung,her soll ich das denn wissen? Überhaupt keine Ahnung oder so Dinge, ja, ich kann mich nicht entscheiden, soll ich meinem Traum nachgehen oder einen sicheren Job nehmen? Ja, woher soll ich, das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem, mit dem jeder Mensch zu kämpfen hat, Sicherheit gegen Hoffnung. Das kann ich doch nicht beantworten. Meine Welt wurde ein bisschen auf den Kopf gestellt, jetzt. Ich dachte immer, ich wüsste alles und ich kann alles checken. Nein, also, Szenario war ein sehr guter Freund von mir, und ich sind immer in ein Café gegangen, wo ... Und der Freund war, muss man sagen, hat sich ein bisschen in die Kellnerin verliebt dort. So, jetzt sind die ganzen Begrifflichkeiten ein bisschen, weil es ein wahrer Fall ist, verändere ich alles ein bisschen, aber das Szenario stimmt im Groben und die Prämisse stimmt. So, und jetzt habe ich dann immer gesagt, schlagt die aus dem Kopf, weil ich denke mir auch, weil ich denke mir auch, wenn ich jetzt wirklich, ja das Gegenteil von einem Hype--Man oder so ein Lasses-Man, so ein Lasses-Komm mal runter wieder. Weil ich dachte mir, weil ich habe da nichts gemerkt und ich will jetzt auch nicht, dass der Freund sich Hoffnungen macht. So, bin ich aus einem netten, vielleicht auch unterbewusst aus, ich will nicht, dass der Freund eine Freundin hat, dann verbringt der weniger Zeit mit mir, vielleicht auch das. aber in meinem Bewusstsein war es eine nette Geste, ich sag ihm, er braucht sich keine Hoffnung machen, daraus wird eh nichts, ich seh doch, wie sie mit ihm spricht.
Also du hattest konkret einen Anlass dazu, du hast gesehen, zwischen denen geht nichts, das eine Seite ist die. Das meine Augen. Also ich habe gesehen, wie sie ihn anguckt und dass sie Augenkontakt vermeidet.
Na ja, gut, das muss ich teissen. Ja, ja, ja, mir später auch lange gemacht. Jedenfalls war ich mir sehr sicher, das wird alles nichts. Und dann habe ich ihm gesagt, komm, schlägt dich aus dem Kopf, das wird nichts. Und er war auch dann immer ein bisschen niedergeschlagen, aber ich habe ihn dann mir aufgepäppelt und gesagt, du willst dich schon finden, verdrink deine Gefühle, fühl dich. Viele anderen Kaffees haben auch schöne Kälterinnen. Genau, so. Bis dann, eines Nachts um vier Uhr nachts, eine Nachricht kam von besagtem Freund, der gesagt hat, Stefan, du glaubst, du bist ein Riesenwichser, du glaubst nicht, was gerade passiert ist, ich war auf Tinder, ich habe sie gesehen, ich habe sie gerideswiped, sie hat mich auch gerideswiped und wir haben geschrieben und ich habe ihr geschrieben, ich liebe dich seit dem ersten Tag, wo ich in deinem Café war und sie hat mir geschrieben, ich ich dich auch seit dem ersten Mal, wo du im Café war. Das kann nicht mehr ernst sein. Und wir sind häufig da gewesen und ich dachte mir, was? Alles, meine ganze Existenz wurde auf links gedreht. Alles, alle meine Ratschläge, also wenn hier irgendwer zuhört, den ich privat kenne, alle Ratschläge, die ich jemals gegeben habe, bitte in Frage stellen. Seitdem gebe ich immer noch sehr aktiv Ratschläge, aber immer das Gegenteil. Du hast mir geraten, Spa aufzumachen, Stefan, die letzten zwei Jahre. Don't, mach's zu. Ich habe über 10.000 Euro investiert. Mach's sofort zu, das Spa. Aber was für eine tolle Geschichte, aber vor allem naja, es ist eine halb tolle Geschichte, weil hätten wir keinen Tinder, wäre diese Liebesgeschichte nie vollendet gewesen. Der schönere Ausgang wäre, jetzt habe ich meine Mutter zusammengenommen, habe sie gefragt und ja und alles ist gut ausgegangen. Aber er hat ja Avancen gestartet. Also er ist ja, er hat schlechte Gags, er ist nach, immer als wir Witz gezahlt haben, nochmal zu, er hat einen Witz gemacht und so. Stopp, er ist aufgestanden und dann nochmal an den Tresen gegangen, um einen Witz zu machen oder während des normalen Kunden. Während des Bezahlvorgangs ist er noch länger da geblieben und hat versucht Smalltalk Versuche gestartet und so weiter. Aber alles an ihm hat gesagt, ich mag dich sehr gerne und ich würde gerne vielleicht mehr Zeit außerhalb dieses Cafes mit dir verbringen. Also an ihm hat viel das ausgestrahlt. Und von ihr kam nichts zurück.
Aber warum kam denn dann nichts von ihr zurück? Kann er nicht da auch mal sagen, hallo, seit zwei Jahren, seit zwei Jahren komme ich jeden Tag in das Café. Kannst du nicht einmal über meinen Gag lachen? Es ist noch nicht so lang, aber tatsächlich hat besagter Freundes auch dann gefragt bei Tinder und es kam zurück, ja, ich war immer so nervös, so nervös, als ich mich getroffen habe und ich habe Augenkontakt vermieden und so, ich war immer noch sehr unsicher, aber ich finde es echt eine irre Geschichte, weil krass, also wie toll aber das jetzt auch ist für ihn, diese und vielleicht habe ich es noch besser gemacht, weil ich vorher nicht Hype Man war, vielleicht hat er sich keine Hoffnung gemacht und kriegt alles. Ja. So, und gewinnt, ist wie jemand, der nicht in Blotto spielt und trotzdem gewonnen hat. Das ist ja immer so dieses Ding zwischen Pessimisten und Optimisten. Bei Pessimisten ist es so, wenn es schlecht wird, können sie sagen, ja, habe ich ja eh gewusst. Und wenn es gut wird, ist es gut, weil es gut ist. Wohegen Optimisten double down so, entweder beides gut oder beides schlecht.
Genau, das dachte ich mir auch dann rückblickend so, eigentlich bin ich der Winner in der ganzen Geschichte. Aber auch diese Anekdote zeigt, Ratschläge sind komplett nutzlos, weil er hat eh gemacht, was er macht, unabhängig davon, was du gesagt hast. Hat er das wirklich oder habe ich ihn nicht dazu gebracht, wie er... Es ist ein unschönes Beispiel, weil die Lösung eine App war, die vor fünf Jahren erfunden wurde, und deswegen sind die Ratschläge ein bisschen schwierig, weil du kannst ja schlecht sagen, ja warte, bis du sie auf Tinder findest, obwohl ich das auch irgendwann vorgeschlagen hätte, versuch sie über einen anderen Weg zu finden. Na guck mal, deine Ratschläge sind gut. Ich gehe straight zu stalken, straight zu stalken. Ich habe gesagt, lass sie einfach in Ruhe, geh weg, anderes Kaffee. Ich hab gesagt, klau ihr Handy, versuch dich bei ihr Facebook-Passwort rauszufinden, stalk sie auf Instagram und versuch so Kontakt herzustellen. Das Problem ist jetzt nur, weshalb ich diese Geschichte dann doch nicht als Happy Ending wahrnehmen würde. Erst mal, wie toll ist es jetzt eigentlich? Beide mögen sich sehr und es ist ausgesprochen. All cards are on the table. Beide wissen, was sie voneinander wollen. So, worauf läuft es hinaus? Du bist raus aus der Freundschaft. Nein, nein, es läuft hinaus auf, die schlafen jetzt einmal miteinander, dann wird es super unangenehm und wir können nicht mehr in das Café, was gut ist. So, darauf wird es noch hinauslaufen. Machen wir uns doch nichts vor, das Café ist jetzt jinxed. Ja, es stimmt schon, weil das ist halt dann so hohe Erwartungen, so, ich bin seit einem Jahren dich verliebt, ja, ich dich auch und dann ist schwer, das einzulösen. Ja, es ist jetzt vorbei, das ist jetzt ja, es sind zu viele Karten, Karten on the table. Ich kenne tatsächlich die gegenteilige Fassung, dass jemand in eine total verliebt ist und alle sagen, ja, jetzt beim nächsten Mal, mach doch das, frag nach ihrer Nummer, mach doch das nochmal, so tu es und die Person es nie tut. Ich war auch schon an der passiven Seite dieser Unterhaltung, so von wegen, ja frag sie doch einfach mal, nie gemacht, nie getan, nichts erreicht, tschau. So, auch hier, Ratschläge bringen nichts, weil ich glaube nicht, dass man den Willen eines Menschen wirklich ändern kann. Ich glaube, Ratschläge dienen, wenn überhaupt, nur einen einzigen Zweck, schon geschloss, schon gefasste Entschlüsse, sich damit besser zu fühlen. Ach so. Also zu sagen so, ja, keine Ahnung, ich habe jetzt Schluss gemacht, ich weiß nicht, ob das richtig war. Und dann ist es die Aufgabe deines Kumpels zu sagen, doch Alter, man hat doch gesehen, es wird nichts mehr. Und dann so Ratschläge. Rationalisieren. Genau. Oder wo man merkt, der will das eh, oder soll ich ich Schluss machen und man merkt, der will schon lange Schluss machen, um dann den Ratschlag zu geben, einfach noch, jetzt hast du es auch nochmal von mir gehört, damit der andere sagen kann, ja, Stefan meint ja auch, ich soll Schluss machen und dann fällt es einem leichter. Aber der Entschluss ist schon gefasst, der ist schon gefasst, da ändert man gar nichts mehr. Was ich einen guten Tipp finde, ist eine Münze zu werfen, wenn du zwischen zwei Entscheidungen und ich nicht, ich bin auch sehr schlecht im Entscheiden. Sehr schlechte Münze werfen, ich verliere viel Geld. Und schlechte Münze werfen, ganz grauenhaft. Ich mache es aber immer an Brunnen. Ja. Naja, jedenfalls, du hoffst für eine Seite. Und es wird dir dabei relativ klar, wenn du das wirklich jetzt, dich dazu bekommst, aber auch zu sagen, okay, ich mache jetzt genau, was diese Münze sagt, du tendierst zu einer Seite, du bist nie bei 50-50.
Das ist das Spannende.
Weißt du, von wem ich diesen Ratschlag das erste Mal gehört habe?
Nein.
Johnny Depp.
Warum?
Ich habe irgendwann mal im Internet so ein Bild gesehen mit so einer Person drauf, Johnny Depp, und mit dem Text, also als Bild, als motivational Bild. Genauso wie ich es da gesagt habe. Und da dachte ich mir, Johnny Depp, gib mir Tipps. Ich meine, warum nicht? Ja, warum nicht? Warum nicht einen Ratschlag von ihm? Ich meine, er hat eine Münze geworfen, bevor er seine Frau geschlagen hat, ich weiß es nicht. War das Johnny Depp? Ich habe keine Art. Ich glaube schon, ja. Nicht, dass sich jetzt Leute durcheinander bringen. Aber ja, es ist schwierig. Aber ich meine, was ist denn Hoffnung für ein Gefühl, das man gut bewerten kann? Ich habe auch schon bei Leuten angerufen und habe gehofft, dass sie nicht abheben. Also hätte ich in dem Moment eine Münze geworfen, hätte ich gesagt, ich hoffe, dass sie nicht abhebt und es ist durch. Also diese Hoffnung bringt einem auch nichts. Ich hoffe immer, dass die Person nicht rangeht. Gebt keine Ratschläge, nehmt keine Ratschläge an, verlasst euch nicht auf andere, dann müsst ihr selber durch. Haltet die Klappe, im Primär. Haltet einfach den Mund, ja. Aber ich hab, also heute war wirklich so ein langweiliger Meeting-Tag und ich muss mal kurz darüber, es ist wirklich interessant, ich glaube der langweiligste Film der Welt ist spannender, weil was Leute sagen, ist halt ausgedacht. So, das schreibt man halt dann auf.
Aber wenn du das aufschreiben würdest, was in einem ganzen Tag, in einem langen Meeting gesagt wird, ich behaupte auch, dass Meetings, die länger als eine Stunde gehen, nicht zielführend sind. Und deswegen, was total spannend ist, Amerikaner machen das häufig, die machen Stand-up-Meetings, wo man steht. Weil dann wollen alle raus. Also der Mensch, wenn er sich erstmal hingesetzt hat, dann ist das erstmal die nächsten drei Stunden seines Lebens. Er weiß, ich sitze, hier bin ich jetzt erstmal. Wenn ein Mensch steht, will er diesen Ort nicht, es ist nicht sein Ziel. So, es ist eine Zwischenstation. Wenn du stehst, willst du irgendwann weg, du willst dich irgendwann hinsetzen. Deswegen glaube ich, ist die Idee eines stehenden Meetings total gut. So werden Leute den ganzen Tag Meeting ungefähr, weiß ich nicht, nur zehn Stunden waren es ungefähr. Und wenn du das mal aufschreiben würdest, was Leute sagen, ich glaube, du würdest durchdrehen. Weil, also wie in dem Meeting gesprochen wird, ist es, die grösstenteils werden Dinge wiederholt, sind nicht zusammenhängend, es ist, du kommst ja nach Stunde eins nicht mehr zu Ergebnissen richtig. Also ich finde es so spannend, wie Leute reden und also das merke ich immer wieder und deswegen will ich auch eigentlich, das ist ja sehr off-topic, aber ich versuche gleich den Kreis zu schliessen, wenn wir beide interviewt werden, dann Dann kommt es ja manchmal so ein Moment, wo man halt ein Interview gibt, mündlich, und dann wird es verschriftlicht. Und dann muss man das nochmal lesen. Die verschriftlichte Version der menschlichen Sprache ist absurd. Du klingst einfach wie der grösste Vollidiot. Und wie gesagt, der langweiligste Film der Welt ist spannend und kohärent im Vergleich, wenn du das mal aufschreiben würdest, was in dem Meeting gesagt wird. Das müsste man mal einfach aufschreiben, wortwörtlich. Es ist ein Haufen Bullshit, wenn man das mal sich betrachten würde, ganz sachlich schwarz auf weiß. Und ich glaube, und das ist mir wieder, neulich wieder passiert, da habe ich ein Interview gegeben und es wurde dann verschriftlicht und man liest sich das durch und denkst, du bist der dümmste Mensch, weil du kannst keinen Satz gerade aussprechen und dann kennt man das ja und ich habe mich damals, ich kenne es von der anderen Seite, als ich damals Journalismus studiert habe, wurde mir irgendwann gesagt, ja, du musst ein Interview mit ihm führen und dann kommt wahrscheinlich von ihm die Ansage, er muss die Zitate von dir nochmal durchgehen, abnehmen und da war ich immer sauer darüber, weil ich gedacht habe, ja, rede doch einfach das, sage doch einfach das, was du sagen willst. Und wenn ich was aus dir rausbekomme, was du bereust, dann ist doch mein Verdienst als guter Journalist, als guter Fragesteller. Warum muss ich jetzt deine Sachen nochmal abnehmen lassen von dir? Mittlerweile auf der anderen Seite dieser Diskussion verstehe ich alles daran. Weil Leute einen, wenn man das einfach nur abschreibt, klingt man der Grösste Vollidiot. Und alle Menschen machen das. Alle Menschen, die Interviews geben, nehmen die Zitate ab und schreiben die noch mal komplett um, damit sie nicht klingen wie der Grösste Vollidiot. Und wenn du der Einzige bist, der es doch einfach lassen, geschehen lässt, bist du ein Idiot.
Und deswegen mache ich das mittlerweile auch und schreibe dann oft die ganze Sache nochmal um. Aber es ist einfach so absurd, warum klingen Menschen so bescheuert, wenn man, wenn man das einfach nur aufnimmt, was jemand sagt. Ja, es ist so, man weiss ja auch oft nicht, wo Sätze hingehen. So, man fängt halt einfach an und dann stellt man sich da irgendwie so durch und kommt irgendwo an. Man hofft, dass man ankommt. Ich würde gerne einmal ein ehrliches Meeting. Ja. So, wo alle ehrlich sind, weil das größte Problem an Meetings, warum Meetings so anstrengend sind, ist, weil man nicht sagen kann, das ist die dümmste Idee, die ich in meinem gesamten Leben je gehört habe. Du verdienst den Job nicht, du bist inkompetent, du bist ein kompletter Vollidiot, raus hier. Ich mag dich nicht, ich mag dich nicht, du laberst nur Mist, du hast Kaffee gebracht, Pluspunkt, du kannst gar nichts, wie heisst du nochmal? So einfach, also sich einfach von seiner Meinung oder von seinem Beitrag zum Geschehen trennen zu können, einfach zu sagen so, nee, finde ich scheiße, weil das sagst du ja nicht, weil der andere dann schmollt und beleidigt ist und dann so. Würde er das nicht tun oder sie, dann wäre es viel besser, weil man sich so von Trennen kann. Wieder schlägst du vor, fühlt nichts. Fühlt nichts oder anonymisierte Meetings, ist mir gerade eingefallen. Man sitzt an einem virtuellen Tisch und jeder hat so eine Bohne. Oder jeder sitzt in so einem Kasten. Jeder setzt sich in so einem Kasten. Ja, aber du weißt ja, wer in welchen Kasten reingegang ist. Du musstest schon anonymisieren. Nee, aber Stimmen sind verfremdet. Ja, so wie bei The Voice. Ja, genau, Stimmen sind alle verfremdet und alle mit dem Rücken. Ja. So dass man einfach sagen kann, weil wenn man sagt, ja, ich fände es viel besser, wenn wir das auf drei Tage aufgliedern, dass wir einfach an einem Tag nicht so viel zu tun haben. Nee, das finde ich eine komplett beschissene Idee. Und du denkst dir, ich weiß nicht, wer es gesagt hat, also kann ich gar nicht emotional reagieren, weil ich nicht sagen kann, Alter, Jochen, was für ein Arschloch. Und du weißt es auch nicht an dich persönlich gerichtet, sondern an die Idee. Und du weißt nicht, wo es kam. Und der andere kann auch ehrlich sein, weil er sagt, es ist einfach eine scheiß Idee. Idee, also es gibt ja verschiedene Stimmen verfremder. Manche machen die Stimme tief, manche machen die sehr hoch, manche machen die so Singlesangel-mäßig. Oder manche zu Marcel Reichernitzki, habe ich auch schon gehört. Genau, so, diese gibt es alle. Jetzt hat jeder, sitzt seinen grossen Raum an einem grossen Tisch. Darum sitzen so eigene einzelne Kästchen. Du siehst zwar, wer wohinter gegangen ist, aber du siehst nicht, wer gerade spricht. Dann kriegt jeder einen Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer auf und Headset. Und jede Stimme wird von jedem verfremdet, per random Zufallsgenerator zu einer random Stimme. Manchmal setzt du dich hin und hast die Fistelstimme, manchmal bist du Reich-Ranitzki. Ich würde sogar sagen, dass die Stimmen sich auch ändern. Dass man nicht weiß, oh, der, der gerade meine Idee schon scheiße findet, findet jetzt meine Idee wieder scheiße, damit du die Stimmen nicht mit Menschen verwechselst. Auf jeden Fall darf bei jedem muss es anders sein. Du darfst nachher nicht sagen können, alter die Fistelstimme war heute so nervig, sondern bei jedem ist die Fistelstimme anders. Also bei jedem ist ein anderer die Fistelstimme und ein anderer Reichern ist. Und nach jeder Wortmeldung wird es geändert. Alle fünf Minuten werden die Verfremder auch geändert, damit man es nicht zusammenführen kann. Weil ich glaube, wenn du sagst, ja wir sollten es es auf drei Tage aufteilen, jemand sagt, das ist eine scheisse Idee, denkst du dir, ja, vielleicht ist es eine scheisse Idee, weil du kannst gar nicht emotional reagieren, weil du es auf niemanden richten kannst. Und du kannst auch ehrlicher sein, weil du weißt, die Person weiss nicht, dass ich gesagt habe, dass es eine scheisse Idee ist und du weißt auch nicht, wer es ist, weil oft findet man Ideen auch scheisse, nur weil sie von niemandem kommen, den man scheisse findet. Und so geht das nicht. Problem hat das auch Probleme, muss man mal ansprechen, und zwar, glaube ich, Witze, Beleidigungen. Ja, durch die Stimmverfremdung, falls man jemanden imitiert, ganz schlecht. Ja, als Reich-Ranicki, Problem. Wobei du, glaube ich, nicht weißt, welche Stimme du bist. Ach so. Ah ja, dann sowas wie Beleidigung. So, Lester-Attack, Mobbing. Hermann, habt ihr heute gesehen, was Hermann trägt? Und dann sagt Hermann was, du Wichser. Also Leute verraten sich, glaube ich, erstens. Oder Hermann selbst fragt, oh, Hermann ist dick geworden, oder? Ist die Christine aus der Buchhaltung nicht scharf, fragt Christine. Oder am Ende redet nur eine einzige Person, das gesamte Meeting, spielt verschiedene Rollen. Ich glaube, ja, ja. Man müsste halt diese Soundboxen in vielen Büros installieren, aber ich glaube, es ist eine gute Idee. Ich glaube auch, es ist primär eine gute Idee, ja. Ich meine, ja, hat Schwächen, aber echte Meetings haben mehr Schwächen, finde ich. Und nach 20 Minuten hört es einfach schlagartig auf. Es geht nichts mehr. Alles ist aus und man muss raus. Ja, wer noch weiterreden will, kriegt einen Stromschlag. Und nichts mehr zu essen. Ja, genau. Für ein Jahr. Also umsonst aus der Firma. Ja. Aber man darf nicht wissen, wer es ist. Aber ganz kurz, um auf das Thema Ratschläge noch mal kurz abzuschliessen, woran man sieht, dass Ratschläge kunde der Bullshit sind. Letzte Woche, also vor zwei Wochen, haben wir gesagt Rollos runter. Letzte Woche haben wir gesagt Rollos hoch, weil ein Hörer gesagt hat, nein, wenn Rollos runter sind, dann brechen Leute ein, weil man weiß, dass niemand da ist. Diese Woche sagen wir wieder Rollos runter, weil die Freundin von einem Hörer arbeitet in der Kriminalistik und hat gesagt, um als Schutz vor Einbrechern Rollos runter, weil die aufzumachen erstens nicht so leicht ist und zweitens es zu lange dauert und zu viel Lärm erzeugt, als dass ein Einbrecher sich das Risiko einnehmen will. Also dritte Woche in Folge, wir drehen wieder um, nochmal, das ist das 180 Grad Info. Nee, kommt mit Corona zur Hälfte runter. Ja, so dass die Schlitze noch offen sind, aber insgesamt zu. Also auch hier, Ratschläge, kompletter Bullshit, weil alles was man als Pro sehen kann, kann man auch als Contra sehen, macht einfach was ihr wollt. Ja, Gesetze sind für den Arsch, Ratschläge machen keinen Sinn. Man kann alles aus zwei Arten auslegen.
Macht alles, was ihr wollt.
Man kann alles immer auf beide Arten auslegen.
Der Mensch ist zu schlau, der Mensch kann zu rationalisieren,
der kann immer beide Seiten von allem sehen.
Und dadurch kannst du immer sagen, du kannst ja so Debattierclubs,
da gibt es ja auch, es gibt ein Thema, Immigration. Und es wir würfeln jetzt bist du dafür oder dagegen du bist dagegen und es geht du kannst dagegen argumentieren du kannst auch dafür argumentieren es geht beides ja vor allem zum gewissen Grad fängt man ja auch dann Dinge zu glauben die man dann sagen muss Manchmal glaube ich, diese Würfel, die du gerade im Konkreten meintest, gibt es ja auch im Kopf. Sowas wie Orte, in denen du geboren wirst, wie wenn du in Ostdeutschland geboren wirst. Ist das vielleicht dein Würfel, ist dein Nazi-Würfel gefallen? Ich weiß noch noch nicht wo das hingeht jetzt aber mal gucken und ich glaube das ist doch interessant wir müssen diese würfel loswerden die leute müssen selber willst nicht mehr dass leute an spezifischen orten geboren werden wir können es ja so wie lachse machen dass alle schwangeren frauen an einen Ort kommen, um da zu gebären. Ja. Und dann gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal. Erst mal das, das reicht ja schon. Mehr muss ein Meeting auch nicht erreichen. Nach 20 Minuten sind wir durch. Nee, ich meine nur, es ist doch cooler, wenn du in diesem metaphorischen Debattierclub für das argumentierst, für das du wirklich bist
und nicht für das,
für das du argumentieren musst. Aber woher weißt du,
dass du wirklich dafür bist? Ja, das ist spannend.
Das meine ich ja gerade. Die Umwelteinflüsse und so weiter,
die zwingen mich ja dazu, Dinge zu meinen.
Und deswegen muss man sich mal
immer bewusst sein, dass es gewürfelt wurde bereits.
Es wurde bereits gewürfelt.
Die Meinung wurde bereits reingesetzt.
Mach dich von deinen Würfeln frei und mach alles und weiss, dass nichts eine Seite hat. Ich glaube, das Einzige, was man machen kann, ist, sich in einen Zustand zu bringen, in dem man bereit ist, seine Meinungen zu ändern. Weil das ist ja das Problem. Sobald du einfach mal eine Meinung hast, hast du zu viel Investitionen. Oh, jetzt habe ich allen erzählt, dass ich diese Parteiei wähle und dann merkst du, die Partei ist scheiße und denkst dir, ich kann jetzt nicht 180 Grad, ich muss weiter Argumente finden, warum sie doch und dann bist du auf dem Weg. Du bist auf dem Highway. Du hast eigentlich schon verloren, weil und deswegen sollte man auch bei anderen Leuten, wenn jemand sagt, ähm, Alter, ich habe richtigen Bullshit erzählt letzte Woche, ich habe meine Meinung komplett geändert, sollte man sagen, geil, alter, super gut, perfekt gemacht, du bist ein Vorbild, weil genau das sollten wir zelebrieren, dass Leute ihre Meinung ändern, weil wir haben alle keine Ahnung, das einzige was man machen kann. Das Internet trichtert einem ja auch ein, den Daumen hoch oder runter zu geben.
Es gibt ja nicht mehr, ich bin ja viel mehr für dieses, nee, so dieses Handschütteln. Ja, was es nicht gibt, es gibt bei YouTube-Videos immer hoch und runter, es gibt nicht dieses, ja, ja, hab ich auch gesehen. Ja. Man muss nicht immer zu allen eine Meinung haben. Das ist auch bei Kinofilmen, wenn man im Kino war und dann würde ich am liebsten immer sofort Kopfhörer aufsetzen, weil ich diese Gespräche dann mal hasse. Ich hasse dieses, wie hat er dir gefallen, mega geil, furchtbar, es gibt nichts dazwischen. Ja. So, das ist mittlerweile, muss man immer diese starke Meinung haben, aber oft ist es doch einfach, no. Ja, ich weiss auch nicht, was eine bessere Frage wäre nach dem Kinofilm, weil ich verstehe, dass man, also es gibt Leute, die wollen über Erlebnisse reden. So, wenn die was erleben, dann wollen sie es teilen und so. Ich bin nicht so eine Person, aber ich verstehe, dass es solche Leute gibt. Die wollen dann sich austauschen und sagen, und wie fandest du es und so. Aber ich weiss auch nicht, was man da konstruktiver machen kann als, wie fandest du es, weil ich kann das oft nach dem Film gar nicht sagen. Ich muss dann erst irgendwie
brauch da eine Zeit.
Es gibt auch einfach manche Filme, zu denen habe ich einfach keine Meinung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich den gut
finde oder nicht. Ich weiß es einfach nicht.
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Ja genau, aber bei Leatherbox gibt es ja keinen
Knopf für
Preises nicht, wie er mir gefallen hat.
Auch wenn ich was esse und jemand fragt
mich und schmeckt es und ich so weiss ich nicht, wie er mir gefallen hat. Auch wenn ich was esse und jemand fragt mich und schmeckt es und ich so ... Weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Keine Ahnung. Ich bin ... Ich werde satt. Also ich ... Es fällt weder positiv noch negativ auf, noch bin ich gelangweilt. Es ist halt, was es ist. Ja. Ja, ja, genau. Ich glaube, da muss man mal hinkommen. Man weiß nicht genau, man muss nicht zu allen eine Meinung haben, Ratschläge sind blöd, keine Ratschläge. Aber trotzdem stets flexibel sein, Meinung und Ratschläge ständig ändern zu werden. Aber weißt du, was du gemacht hast letzte Woche? Nee. Du hast mich inspiriert. Ja? Weil du hast ja erzählt von Haferflocken plus Banane und ich habe dir erzählt von der Haferflockenpackung, die seit Einzug bei mir rumliegt.
Und was habe ich auf dem Heimweg gemacht? Die würde ich nicht so lange noch da stehen lassen, damit er essen. Auf dem Heimweg bin ich schön Supermarkt gefahren, keine Banane, sondern Himbeeren. Lecker Himbeeren geholt, Milch, Haferflockenpackung aufgemacht. Mandelmilch war ja die Idee eigentlich. Ja genau, ich habe auch Mandelmilch, aber die ungesüßte. Ja genau, klar,, die ungesüste. Und dann aufgemacht und dann, da waren Fliegen am Start, aber ich weiß nicht genau, ob sie aus der Packung kamen oder nicht.
Also das Problem war, ich habe meine Wohnung gelüftet und bin dann hierher gefahren zur Aufnahme, bin dann wieder zurückgefahren, habe gemerkt, fuck, meine Küchenlicht war die ganze Zeit an, plus das Fenster war die ganze Zeit offen und es war Nacht. Sprich, hundert Fliegen sind reingekommen. So, und dann habe ich die Haferflockenpackung aufgemacht und dann waren Fliegen in der Nähe. Und dann kann man so eine Fliege ja ... Was war denn die Flugrichtung der Fliege? Ja, es war eine Müdigkeit, glaube ich. Ich glaube, ich habe eine Müdigkeit gesehen, die vielleicht daraus resultieren könnte, dass man seit vier Monaten in seiner Hauptnahrungsquelle lebt. Aber es ist nicht eher eine Euphorie, eine ... Da draußen gibt es auch noch eine Welt. Ich weiß es, stell dir mal vor, du bist eine Fliege in so einer Haferflockenpark. Erstmal leben die keine vier Monate. Punkt eins. Die leben vier Tage. So, und es ist dann nicht ein bisschen Platons Höhlen-Gleichnis, dass wenn du dann das aufmachst, dass die erstmal, dass du eben keine gewisse Müdigkeit feststellen solltest, sondern ein What the fuck is happening? Aber bei Plato wurden die ja in der Höhle geboren. Die Fliege wurde ja nicht in der Höhle geboren, die kam ja. Ja, aber das meine ich ja genau. Wahrscheinlich wurde sie in der Höhle geboren. Ach so, in der Haferhöhle. Ja, ja klar. So oder so denkt man sich dann, selbst wenn die jetzt von dieser Haferpackung kommt. Also es ist ja kein Grund, es nicht zu essen, weil wenn ich jetzt nicht direkt fliehen esse, was auch nicht schlimm wäre. Der Kreis schliesst sich. Es gibt ähnlich viele Gründe dafür, die es nicht zu essen, wie die einfach zu essen, ist es einfach. Ich habe mir diese Flieger angeguckt und habe mir geguckt, wie groß ist der Mund. Und ich habe den Mund nicht mal gefunden. Und da dachte ich mir, der selbst, der muss so klein sein. Und die Flieger ist so, oh, was ist der Fliege auf dem Boden? Kann man jemand ein Bild schicken von der Nahrung, die eine Fliege in ihrem gesamten Leben isst, auf einem Haufen? Ist es mehr oder weniger als eine Haferflocke, weil der Mensch, der isst bestimmt ein ganzes Haus voller Nahrung, wenn man das jetzt einfach an Materie. Ich glaube, ja. Oder würdest du eher sagen Zimmer oder ein Haus? Ich würde sagen drei Häuser. Drei Häuser. Drei Häuser Lebensmittel. Sag mal von diesen genormten Containern auf so Schiffen. Wie viele von diesen, weil Haus ist jetzt auch relativ, von diesen Containern. In einem Leben. Also jetzt und natürlich nicht an Kalien, sondern wirklich das gesamte Essen an Volumen, das man gisst. Also gut, es ist natürlich eine Packung Kellogg's größer als der Inhalt. Muss man auch mal sagen. Reden wir jetzt von einem ... Ich rede nicht von der Packung. Ich rede nur von dem tatsächlich gegessenen Essen. Also wenn ich jetzt eine Packung Tresor esse, würde der Container, da würde jetzt dann die Packung Tresor ausgeschüttet werden. Ja genau, der Haufen Tresor. Nicht die Packung Tresor. Vergiss die Packung. Gut, dann würde ich sagen, verunterschätzt Volumen nicht, man unterschätzt Volumen. Ich würde sagen, zwölf Container. Zwölf? Ne, voll. In dem Leben doch, zwölf Container. Und ich glaube, ich habe schon dreizehn gegessen. Mitteleuropäer zwölf Container. Volumen? Du unterschätzt mir Volumen. Alleine wenn du so einen Salat, wie viel Salat du gegessen hast in deinem Leben schon. Ja, aber die sind riesig.
Naja, ich sag zwei Container. Was? Ich sag zwei Container. Und eigentlich nach unserem Gesetz der Massen stimmt jetzt wieder die Mitte, wie wir gesagt haben. Also irgendwo zwischen sechs und sieben ist die Wahrheit. Falls es jemand weiß, schickt uns das Bild, schickt uns das Bild von der Fliege, weil ich dachte mir, so eine Haferflocke reicht für die Fliege das gesamte Leben, weil ich denke mir so, manchmal ist es ja, manchmal verliere ich mich selbst. Aber stopp, ganz kurz mal, wie oft würdest du selbst denn in so einen Container reinpassen? Sagen wir so zwei, eineinhalb hoch, zehn, vier mal, zwanzig, allein ist ja schon mehr als hundert mal, dreihundert, vierhundert mal. In einem nein. Wir haben hier auf dem Hof einen Container stehen, da passe ich längs vielleicht vier mal rein und die schräge Seite, die ist deutlich länger, ich würde sagen, passt man so zwölf mal rein vielleicht. Zwölf mal? Ja, vier mal zwölf. Ja, vier mal zwölf.
Okay, sagen wir mal hundert. Wie oft Wird ich sagen, packen wir so zwölf Mal rein vielleicht. Zwölf Mal?
Ja, vier mal zwölf.
Okay, sagen wir mal hundert.
Wie oft, wie lange brauchst du, um dein eigenes Körpergewicht zu essen an Essen?
Wie viele Tage?
Die längste Folge aller Zeiten. Weiß ich nicht, wie viel, jetzt mal. Einen Monat? Ja, jetzt hast du einen Monat mal 100. Zehn Jahre. Und dann würdest du 130 Jahre leben in deinen Containern. Ja, wir wissen es nicht, aber also, ich tue es antworten. Ich denke mir nur, wenn ich halt mal so ein, manchmal verliere ich mich und esse so ein Bucket bei KFC. So ein Bucket, da sind 18 Hähnchen, Chicken Wings drin, 18 Stück, neun Hühner, neun. Ja, aber du isst ja nicht die Knochen, du isst ja nur das Fleisch. Ja, aber neun Hühner sind deswegen draufgegangen. Und ich bin ja noch in meinem Verpackungsding. Ja, das ist total absurd. Ich bin noch in meinem Verpackungsding. Also sowas, was Tresor, die Tresorverpackung zum kleinen Mini-Tresor-Pocket ist, ist das Huhn zum Chicken Wing. Deswegen würde ich sagen, also wenn es um Verpackungen auch geht und Dinge, die dranhängen mit, es sind so viele Containers, kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Ich glaube, du unterschätzt Volumen. Was mich, das hast du gerade das Gegenteil gesagt. Wie, oder? Ach so, nee, du hast gerade das Gleiche gesagt. Deswegen wundert mich auch, dass du so wenig Container gesagt hast. Wir warten aber, also ich habe auf jeden Fall Haferflocken verzehrt, waren sehr lecker, Himbeeren hat sehr gut funktioniert, ich bin großer Fan generell von Himbeeren, war richtig lecker. Ich habe neulich Comedians in Cars, Gilding Coffee geschaut und auch da sind die Roller zu sehen gewesen, Lime.
Ein Lime-Roller war in L.A., stand da rum.
Und da dachte ich dann irgendwann, holy fuck, auf der ganzen Welt sind plötzlich diese Roller erschienen, aus dem nichts.
Wie so Independence Day-artig von so einem Mutterschiff gebracht worden, sind die auf der ganzen Welt plötzlich hingestellt worden.
Seit wann ist das im Gange? Seit wann passiert das schon?
Ohne dass wir davon wussten, wurden diese Roller produziert in den letzten fünf Jahren.
Und die ganze Welt wurde von Nacht, über Nacht überschwemmt von diesen Rollern.
Ich finde das total mindgläuig.
Man guckt ja, man weiss ja nicht, was alles so ist in so einer Stadt.
So wenn man mal in irgendeine Random-Tür in der Stadt reinguckt.
Und dann spürt man einfach so Hunderte von diesen Rollern und denkt sich, okay.
Ja, und denkt sich bitte, was ist los?
Nächstes Jahr. Und was man ja hoff oft sieht, sind ja zwei Jugendliche gleichzeitig drauf. Auf einem Roller. Ja, ja, verstehe ich schon. Und dachte ich mir heute eigentlich, es ist eine neue Form von Romantik eigentlich. Ach so, ich dachte gerade von Betrug. Nee, das sind zwei verschiedene Richtungen. Ja, ja, das beschreibt uns ganz gut. Also ich komme ja vom Lande und da gibt es, ich glaube, es gibt einen sehr grossen Unterschied zwischen Landjugendlichen Romantik und Stadtjugendlichen Romantik. Und Landjugendlichen Romantik ist ja viel dann so Lagerfeuer, aber dann vor allem auch dieses, der eine, der einen coolen Roller hat, mit ihr hinten drauf. So, das ist ja so das Ultimum. Sie umarmt ihn dann. Genau, das Ultimum. Weil das muss ihn ja festhalten. Und ich dachte mir auch damals, so ein Roller wär's eigentlich. Ich hab relativ schnell dieses Thema begraben und hab mich meinen Warhammer-Figuren gewidmet. Aber dachte ich mir immer, so ein Roller eigentlich ist es. So auf die Dorffeier fahren, dann Lagerfeuer und dann, ah, man fährt dann zusammen zurück, was auch immer so. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, das ist auch eine Form von der aktuellen Jugendkultur. Die werden dann irgendwie in zehn Jahren sagen, ach, damals wir beide auf dem Roller. So, es gibt ja so Bilder, wenn du so einen Film drehen müsstest, so Coming of Age, dann gibt es so Bilder, in der Amerikanischen ist es dann oft so das Auto, wo man dann zu viert ist mit den beiden Kumpels so. Ja. Und vielleicht wird es ein bisschen ersetzt durch diese Roller, wenn sich das hält. Kann sein. Ich dachte jedenfalls, wenn so von einem Jahr irgendwie so ein Obdachloser in so ein Haus gegangen und dann standen da diese Roller überall, da hat es das Licht angemacht und es geht so eine Leuchtturfe nach der anderen an. Anflackern. Und es ist eigentlich so ein Haus, so ein wohnlichen Reihenhaus und es ist einfach nur rein, weil die Tür offen stand plötzlich und dann geht ein Licht nach dem anderen an und er guckt, so kilometerweit stehen dann so Roller von Lime und Cirque und er läuft durch die Stadt und sagt, das ist alles eine Lüge, da sind überall so Roller.
Und alle sagen, du bist verrückt, du trinkst zu viel.
Und dann sitzt er hier und denkt, fuck.
Und irgendwo drückt irgendjemand auf einen großen Knopf und bei allen Rollern ging gleichzeitig das Licht an und alle so schau nach links und fahren so langsam raus.
Das war zu tief. Ein bisschen zu tief. Ja, aber das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es passiert ist. Ich glaube, vor allem, ich weiß noch genau, ich glaube, wir haben Folge fünf oder so, da kam der Segway. Und du hast gesagt, der Segway wird die Zukunft sein, niemand wird mehr Autos benutzen, weil der Segway ist so klein und handlich und so schnell. Ich habe auch gedacht, die Roller habe ich komplett übersehen. Aber warum hat der Segway sich nicht durchgesetzt, warum hat es nicht funktioniert und jetzt kommen diese Roller und machen es vor, einfach weil es eine Form ist, weil der Segway zu albern ist oder weil es eine Form ist, die man schon kennt als Roller? Nee, ich glaube, die Technik ist so kompliziert. Diese nach vorne lehntechnische Technik ist nicht so intuitiv. Ich glaube, du musst da relativ viel für lernen. Ich glaube, diese Roller sind relativ einfach. Erstmal, jedes Kind hat ja schon mal einen Roller in seinem Leben. Und das finde ich auch wirklich spannend, dass diese Roller, also ich verstehe auch diese Hands-Free-Segways nicht, diese Hoverboards, die machen dann gar keinen Sinn eigentlich. Die haben es ja auch mal durchgesetzt so ein bisschen, hatte ich ja auch mal eins, muss man auch mal sagen, und damit kannst du ja nicht mehr bei den Bordsteinen fallen, eher so gefährlich, weil die beiden Motoren auch angesteuert werden, getreht voneinander, dann dreht eins durch und dann liegst du da wieder auf dem Boden und lachen dich aus und sagen, ha ha ha. Aber mich wundert, also du versperrst dich diesem Trend Elektrorolle jetzt total, oder was? Du warst ja mal als Stefan der Flitzer bekannt, mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
E-Mobilitäts-Flitzer, Stefan, ja. Du versperrst dich diesem Trend Elektrorolle jetzt total, oder was? Nee, gar nicht. Du warst ja mal als Stefan der Flitzer bekannt, mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
E-Mobilitäts-Flitzer, Stefan, ja.
Nee, ich fahr die sehr aktiv.
Ach ja.
Ja, ach ja. Ich fahr die sehr, sehr aktiv und ich verstehe auch nicht mehr, wie man vorher durch Städte gekommen ist.
Also ich bin da, seitdem diese Roller am Start sind, fahr ich wirklich, bin ich, weiß nicht, 150 Prozent mehr an anderen Orten, als ich vorher war.
An mehr Orten. Ich habe Köln erschlossen jetzt ein bisschen. Kennt man ja. Wenn du bei Pokémon das Fahrrad bekommst, bist du schneller. Du erschließt die Karte schneller. Wenn du diese Tretschuhe bekommst, wo du plötzlich schneller gehst, kannst du dir besser etwas erschließen. In jedem Abenteuer-Game kommst du irgendwann an diesen Punkt, bei Zelda kriegst du dieses Segel, dieses Parasegel und kannst rumfliegen, irgendwo kannst du vielleicht mal ein Pferd besteigen, bei GTA kannst du ein Auto klauen. Alle diese Spiele haben diesen einen Moment, wo du etwas bekommst, und dann bist du schneller. Und das habe ich das Gefühl, ist jetzt in meinem Alter von 25 Jahren passiert. Ja. Und du musst Level 25 erreichen, um diese Roller zu bekommen. Die Musik ändert sich plötzlich. Du kannst in Zonen, die du vorher nicht konntest. Genau, Grafik ist ähnlich schlecht. Immer noch, trotzdem kriege ich jetzt diese Roller, und ich habe mir die Karte ein bisschen erschlossen. Und jetzt denkst du dir, oh, Moment mal, als ich acht war, hätte ich da hinfahren können, wenn ich diesen Roller gehabt hätte, da fahre ich jetzt noch mal hin. Und dann guckst dir nochmal so backtracking, guckst dir nochmal alles an, wo du warst. Das Ding ist genau, bei Pokémon würde man sich das auch immer merken, da hinten war dieser Baum, den man nicht durchschneiden konnte, weil man keinen Zerschneider hatte. Oder da konnte ich nicht hoch, weil ich keine Kaskade hatte. Kraxler, ich weiß es nicht. Ja, Kletterer. Dinge, Ego-Sekar. Greifer. So, und das merkt man sich ja auf dem Weg aber nicht.
Das ist mein Problem.
Ich habe ein zu schlechtes Gedächtnis, um mir zu merken, was ich hätte entdecken können, den ich jetzt nicht im Roller hätte.
Aber ist das vielleicht nicht ein Modell, weil wir haben jetzt unseren Hörern viele Dinge genommen, also Meinungen und Ratschläge, vielleicht können wir ihnen diese Backtracking-Skills geben, zu überlegen, welche Skills habe ich heute, mit denen ich jetzt Probleme lösen könnte von vor fünf Jahren und da einfach nochmal zurück und sagen könnte, ich bin jetzt ein reiferer Mensch, sollte ich nicht vielleicht dann doch den nochmal anrufen und sagen, hey, das, was ich damals gemacht habe, war scheiße, lass uns das nochmal aufarbeiten. Das Sudoku von damals aus der Bahn. Nochmal die Schublade aufmachen, sagen, das knacke ich jetzt. Nochmal die angefangene Bachelorarbeit rausholen und sagen, kann ich es jetzt?
Aber genau gegenteilig auch mal sagen, wenn man vor Problemen steht, einfach sagen, tue ich die Schublade, merke ich mir, das ist jetzt mein Zerschneiderbaum und in einem Jahr habe ich vielleicht die VM und komme dann locker durch, aber jetzt geht es halt gerade nicht. Jetzt geht es gerade nicht, akzeptiere ich auch, weil das Spiel ist so programmiert, dass ich das noch nicht schaffen muss. Alles gut, alles gut, ich bin auf dem richtigen Weg. Wenn du gerade mit der Schule abgeschlossen hast und sagst, ich weiss nicht wohin, denk dir einfach das ist jetzt mein Zerschneiderbaum, geh erstmal in die Poké-Villa, hol dir erstmal einen Feuerorden und komm dann nochmal zurück. Der Poké-Villa ist der Feuerorden? Lass das einfach mal nebenbei stehen und mach erstmal was anderes. Genau wie, ich treibe jetzt mal weiter mit den Pokémon-Metaphern. Manchmal kommst du in Gebiete, da ist das hohe Gras zu gefährlich. Du bist noch nicht bereit für Gebiete, in denen die Pokémon zu stark sind. Du hast plötzlich eine Abkürzung genommen, die du nicht hättest nehmen können. Und die Player da sind zu krass. Geh zurück nochmal
und trainier deine Pokémon hoch.
Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja gut, aber du brauchst
ja starke Gegner, um selber stark zu werden.
Ich behaupte,
das macht mehr Spaß, wenn du
stark genug bist, um diese Gegner zu besiegen.
Geh nochmal zurück,
geh fünf Stunden zurück,
studier nochmal.
Ich weiß selber noch nicht genau, wo das hingeht. Ich vers verstehe, ich verstehe. Ich versuche das Bitten noch weiterzutreiben. Studier nochmal, also trainier dein Pokémon, geh zurück und besiege die Gegner. Andere Metapher, wenn ihr ein Pokémon habt und ihr habt da viel Zeit reingesteckt und ihr merkt, das bringt nichts, die Aquaknarre, die reisst es einfach nicht. Auch einfach mal den Mut haben, Pokémon wegschmeissen, neues Pokémon und nochmal von vorne anfangen. Klammert euch nicht an die Vergangenheit. Setzt nicht alles aufs gleiche Punita. Richtig. Nicht alles aufs gleiche Punita setzen, wenn ihr versteht, was ich immer. So, ne? Nicht alle Owei in einem Korb. Du kannst nicht Owei mit Kokowai vergleichen. Ja, ja, ja. So, das ist, genau, manchmal muss man auch einfach, genau, einfach, das ist auch ein wichtiger, wichtiger, wichtiger Trick. Was kann man noch? Wenn ihr Dinge nicht schafft, alleine, könnt ihr auch mal Dinge in die Pension geben, die andere Leute kümmern sich um eure Probleme. Da muss man auch mal klar sein. Ihr müsst nicht jedes Problem lösen können. Ihr müsst nicht jedes Pokémon trainieren können. Ihr müsst nur wissen, wo ist die Pension. Richtig. Und oft kennt man es ja, man sammelt Items ein und hat ganz viele Items und irgendwann ist der Beutel voll. Items ruhig auch mal raushauen bei der erstbesten Gelegenheit. Ja, oh ich habe fünf Punkte Schaden direkt den Supertrank drauf. Genau. Oh, ich habe den Hyperball, sollte ich mir den aufheben für ein wichtiges Pokémon, was irgendwann kommt? Nein, das nächste Taubsieg wäre ich ein fucking Hyperball.
Rettan direkt Hyperball, ja es gibt kein Overkill, einfach drauf damit. Der schlechteste Hyperball ist der, den man gar nicht wirft. Wow. Jeder Hyperball auf den Rettan ist besser als der, den man gar nicht wirft. Wow. Jeder Hyperball auf den Rettern ist besser als der, den man gar nicht wirft. Und vielleicht ist es das Rettern, was euch später den Sieg in der Pokeliga beschert. Unwahrscheinlich, aber sehr unwahrscheinlich. Wirklich unwahrscheinlich. Ja, aber es müssen doch nicht alle die Pokeliga. Du kannst ja auch Spaß haben, du musst ja nicht der sein, der die Pokeliga durchspielt. Richtig. Wenn man mal sagt, so ein Johnny Depp hat die Pokeliga durchgespielt, im Leben jetzt. Du musst nicht die Pokeliga durchspielen. Du kannst auch ein gutes Leben, du kannst auch wieder zu deiner Mutter zurückgehen, in dieses Anfangsdorf, Alabastia. Kannst auch da ein gutes, kannst auch da Barista werden oder sowas. Kannst auch ein gutes Leben. Alabarista ist da alles drin. Ja. Und manchmal, wenn das Spiel zu schwer ist, schau in die Komplettlösung. Schau nach, wo ist der Türöffner, wo ist Silvescope. Guck nach, sei dir nicht zu schade, auch einfach mal hinten auf die Packung zu gucken. Das habe ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden. Wie soll das im Leben funktionieren? Wie soll ich jetzt da die Komplettlösung gucken? Einfach sich nicht zu schade sein, die richtige Hilfe zu holen. Ja, das eigene Ego hinten anstellen. Ja, aber nach der Metapher müsste ich ja jetzt eine Lösung finden für meine Probleme, also die direkte. Wie … Auch mal seinen Stolz runterschlucken und zu sagen, ich rufe jetzt bei der Hotline an und sag, pass auf, ich bin hier in diesem Team Rocket Gebäude, ich fliege hier von links nach rechts, von rechts nach links seit Tagen. Die Grafik lässt mich nicht erkennen, ob es sich jetzt um Beamer handelt oder was. Auch immer bin ich gerade, ich komme auf dieses Feld und schwuppdiwupp bin ich im achten Gebäude. Hier geht's nicht mit rechten Dingen zu. Hier liegen Items rum, aber mein Beutel ist voll, ich kann sie nicht aufheben. Und jetzt nach einer Woche und hundert Spielstunden rechts nach links. Das will ich mal sehen, wie das jemand, wie diese Frage mal in der Hotline gestellt wird. Ich fliege von rechts nach links in der Pokémon-Welt, ein durchaus bekanntes Problem. Ja. Auch dass man durch eine Höhle geht, die stockfinster ist. Auch ein ganz normales. Ich glaube, wir haben uns ein bisschen schrapaziert. Ich habe tatsächlich mal bei der Hotline angerufen. Bei der Pokémon Hotline. Und das Erbärmliche daran ist... Was? Ich muss bis gerade gar nicht, dass die existieren. Ja, es existiert, das gab es früher zu sehr, sehr vielen Spielen, gab es Hotlines, Lösungs-Hotlines und Hilfe-Hotlines, die du anrufen konntest, wenn du nicht weiterkommst. Und das Erbärmliche daran war, dass ich auch die Komplettlösung hatte. Und mein Problem war, ich stand von einer verschlossenen Tür und habe in der Komplettlösung gesehen, dass es einen Türöffner gibt, das Item Türöffner. Das war aber ein Level weiter. Und ich kam nicht durch die Tür, um den Türöffner zu holen. So geht es mir im Leben aber auch häufig. Ich weiss grob, was ich machen müsste, sie ansprechen, aber ich bin doch nicht so weit mit meinen Dating Skills, dass ich sie ansprechen würde. Das heisst, ich sehe, ich weiss, wie der Türöffner liegt, aber ich bin doch nicht in dem Level, den fucking Türöffner zu bekommen. Dein Auto ist abgeschlossen, aber der Schlüssel zu deinem abgeschlossenen Auto ist im Auto. Wie kann das Auto zu sein? Das frage ich dich jetzt mal. Ich sehe den Schlüssel. Wie soll es denn zugegangen sein, das Auto? Aber es ist im geschlossenen Auto.
Und dann habe ich angerufen und habe gesagt, ja, hier muss ein Fehler vorliegen in dem Spiel, weil...
Und was das, wer war da seine Macht? Oh, also jetzt wüsst es gehen.
Nochmal ausschalten, einschalten, dann geht's.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin hier von der verschlossenen Tür.
Da hängt ein Fehler vor.
Der Türöffner. Nee, du hast doch alle, bei allen ist das falsch.
Ja.
Aber das sind doch Freunde, die es geschafft haben.
Mein Kumpel Jakob in der Schule war weiter. Ich dachte mir, da muss mein Spiel falsch sein. Ehrlich gesagt, ich stehe hier von der verschlossenen Tür, der Türöffner ist aber erst im nächsten Level, also irgendwas kann er nicht ganz koscher sein. Und dann meinte er, du musst den Trainer besiegen, dann geht die Tür auf. Wow, aber alles entzaubert. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann vor allem, ja, mein Freund war im Glitch-Level. Es gibt ja diese Glitch-Stadt, durch die man reinkommt, wenn man crazy Sachen macht. Und dann ist alles dann, die Graphics sind alle falsch. Und dann dachte der so, na, er dachte, er hätte das Spiel gemeistert, so. Ah, ich rufe jetzt mal bei der Hotline an. Der spielt noch so viel Hass mit in der Stimme. Ich rufe... Ja, das ist wirklich... Es gab ein anderes Kind, das Pokémon gespielt hat in der Klasse und es ist zufällig das Kind, das ich nicht gemocht habe, aber ich habe Pokémon geliebt. Und deswegen musste ich mit ihm tauschen, was Link gab.. Stimmt. Ja, weil ich wollte fucking Simpsala.
Und der hat dann auch bei der Hotline angerufen und meinte so, ja, ich bin jetzt in diesem Level irgendwie, wo alles ganz komisch ist und in diesem Glitch-Level. Ist mir wohl irgendwas gelungen, was... Und er so, ja, dann musst du nochmal neu starten. Was macht der heute? Ich frag mich, wer in dieser... Was macht der Snob, den du gerade da sprichst, heute? Vor allem, das war wahrscheinlich ein 21-jähriger Student, der irgendwie so einen Job der Welt hat. Eigentlich mit dem besten Job der Welt, aber der hat wahrscheinlich nebenbei irgendwie, es gab kein YouTube, es gab kein Internet, es gab nichts. Das war der Cutting-Edge-Technologie, jemanden anzurufen und zu fragen, wie man mit seinem Videospiel weiterkommt. Wahnsinn, aber coole Idee. Hat er den ganzen Tag mit neunjährigen Kindern gesprochen, die ja, ich finde in der Safari-Zone keinen Surfer, und dann sagt er, ja, du musst erst rechts, dann hoch, dann links, dann links, dann runter. Ich finde, es sind fünf Fragen, die gestellt werden, glaube ich. Ich glaube, es sind nicht viele Fragen. Es sind immer die gleichen fünf. Ja, das war bei mir im Callcenter genauso. Neunzig Prozent der Anrufe waren eine einzige Frage. Ja. Und deswegen ... Was war deine Frage? war deine Frage? Bei mir war, ich habe die Nummern eingegeben, aber es geht nicht. Und ich habe gefragt, haben Sie die Nummern eingetippt oder haben Sie die Nummern gesprochen? Ja, die habe ich gesprochen. Nein, nein, nein. Sie müssen die Nummern eintippen. Ach so, ja, schreibt es doch dazu. So, das war immer wildes Zeichen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Ja, fickig. Das war, wie ich 90 Prozent Anrufe. Selbst wenn jemand ein ganz anderes Thema hatte, so, ja, ich habe jetzt die Nachricht bekommen, und ich so, haben sie denn noch mal eingetippt, oder haben sie sie gesagt? Nur um das mal aus dem Weg zu schaffen. Weil du hast 90 Prozent, hast du damit schon rausgekegelt. Ich behaupte aber auch, 90 Prozent diese eine Frage, restliche 10 Prozent unlösbare Probleme.
Absolut.
Oder?
Ja, ja.
Fehler, weirde Fehler, die du nicht ergründen kannst jetzt.
90 Prozent ein Problem, acht Prozent verwählt, ein Prozent merkt selber, während er das Problem beschreibt, ein Prozent völlig unlösbar.
Unlösbar, genau.
Und deswegen, ich verstehe schon den Impuls von Websites, diese FAQs hinzuschreiben, die aber nicht richtig funktionieren. Bei mir lösen die nie die Probleme. Ich behaupte aber auch, dass ich IT-mässig, das ist ja meistens IT-Probleme, so versiert bin, dass ich die Dinge, die da stehen bei den FAQs erstmal schon versuche, selber herauszufinden und so. Aber meistens stellen die dann dann nicht und dann suche ich immer eine Hotline, die man dann nicht findet. Das ist häufig ein Problem. Man schafft ja Hotlines ab, weil Leute, glaube ich, um dieses Problem wissen, dass meistens nur eine Frage gestellt wird. Ich hatte letztens echt ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil ich war in so einem Wutmodus. In so einem Modus, wo man nicht stolz darauf ist, dass man in diesem Modus ist. Und ich habe nach einer Lösung gesucht für ein Problem mit Updates und Flash, Adobe, Bullshit, also wirklich Schwachsinn. Und hab gesucht und dann kam ich auf so eine Adobe-Seite, wo dann erklärt wurde. Und es war einfach daneben, es war genau daneben. Ich wollte genau das wissen, was in dem Satz gekommen wäre, der zwischen zwei Absätzen war. So dieses, ja, wählen Sie das Symbol an und machen Sie dann und ich so, wo ist das Symbol? Und er so, beschreibt hundertmal, ja, wenn Sie das Symbol mit links anklicken, wenn sie es mit alt anklicken und du so, ich will nur wissen, wo es ist. Und ganz unten war dann, war dieser Artikel hilfreich.
Und ich habe gesagt, nein, weil ich habe nicht das bekommen, was ich wollte.
Und dann nochmal zurück ins Programm, sofort gefunden, Problem gelöst, alles weg, Blutpegel senkt sich.
Und dann hatte ich ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil ich dachte, ich mir, eigentlich hat er nicht dieses Nein verdient. Weil es ist nicht die Aufgabe. Doch. Denn, na ja. Doch, der muss auch den Lücken antizipieren. Aber man muss auch so fair sein und einfach sagen, da war ich einfach dumm. Du bist nicht zurückgegangen, als auf Jager klickt. Nein. Ich habe die Seite nochmal aufgerufen. Nein, woher soll ich denn wissen? Ich habe die Seite nochmal aufgerufen. Du hast deine Nachwelt in Mittelbitteln gezeigt und wollte meinen Thumbsdown entfernen und es ging nicht. Ja, zu Recht. Und ich habe mich so schlecht gefühlt, es ist wie wenn du eine Katze auf den Schwanz trittst und der nicht erklären kannst, dass es dir leid tut. So war es da, ich konnte dieser Seite nicht mehr sagen, ey, ich war gerade wütend, ich war gerade in dem Modus, auf den bin ich nicht stolz, ich habe da aus Affekt draufgeklickt, ich wollte es nicht. Ja, also, im neuen Fitnessstudio sieht man häufig auch an Flughäfen diese Dinger, diese Ständer, wo draufsteht, wie gefällt es ihnen hier, oder waren sie mit dem Service zufrieden und du hast einen roten und einen grünen und einen gelben Smiley.
Und die haben den aber so clever positioniert. Ich bin nie zufrieden da. Ich hasse es da. Ich habe auch keinen Spaß da. Ich mag die ganzen Leute, stellen ihre Gewichte nicht zurück. Ich hasse es. Alles daran hasse ich an dieser Experience. Es riecht merkwürdig in der Männerung, alles riecht komisch, überall ist Schweiß, alles widerlich. Und trotzdem traue ich mich nicht auf diesen roten Smiley zu drücken, weil der so clever positioniert ist, was die aber, die kriegen ja nie das Resultat, was sie wollen, weil der zum Raum hinsteht. Alle sehen, was ich drücken würde. Der steht mittendrin, zur länglichen Seite des Flures. Das ganze Studio würde sehen, wenn ich da hinlaufe und auf Rot klicke.
Alle würden sich wundern, was hat er denn? Und warum kommt er denn wieder? Verschwörungstheorie? Diese Konsole ist an nichts angeschlossen. Das sind drei Knöpfe, die nichts angeschlossen sind. Du meinst es wie der kleine Bruder, den man so einen Controller gibt, der nicht angeschlossen ist? Ja, weil wahrscheinlich hat irgendjemand mal rausgefunden, wenn die Kunden auf so einen roten Knopf drücken und denken, damit würden sie das bewirken, sinkt die Beschwerderate um 80%. Es reicht. Und seitdem sagt die, ja gut, dann hol ich mir so ein Ding auch. Alles gut. Ist das angeschlossen? Nee, stell das einfach da hin. Ja, ja. Weil wahrscheinlich du den Kunden auch ein besseres Gefühl gibst, wenn sie eine schlechte Erfahrung haben, dann ist es ja umso frustrierender, wenn sie es niemandem mitteilen können und sich denken, so wütend wie ich bin, niemand kriegt es mit, es ändert sich nichts und dann sagen sie, jetzt haue ich auf diesen roten Knopf. Und dann denkt man sich, na gut, ich habe jetzt mein Feedback gegeben und ich habe denen die Chance gegeben, es zu verbessern, beim nächsten Mal ist es vielleicht besser. Natürlich ist es nicht besser, nichts passiert, aber man hat ein besseres Gefühl. Ich glaube, das ist psychologisch genial, dieses Ding einzubauen, obwohl es überhaupt keinen Effekt hat. Weil es hat sowohl auf die Kunden einen guten Effekt, die ihren Frust ablassen können, als auch für den Besitzer, die weniger Beschwerden bekommen, weil die Kunden sich da schon abreagieren konnten. Ja, man kann sich da ablassen, ist wie so ein Boxsack. Ja. Ja, ist interessant. Ich habe noch nicht mal, musste ich mal fünf Sterne-Bewertungen geben, war für zu weit. Ich meine, muss ich, fünf Sterne Bewertungen sind, wenn man die ernst nimmt, nicht lösbar. Fünf Sterne Bewertungen, das System Fünf Sterne Bewertungen funktioniert nicht, wenn du es ernst meinst, weil, also aus Wut verstehe ich, gibt man einen Stern oder fünf Sterne, weil man sich sehr freut. Also wenn du Emotionalität aber abziehst, kannst du eigentlich weder einen noch fünf Sterne geben, weil das eine ist zu übertrieben gut, das andere ist zu übertrieben schlecht. Das heißt, eigentlich ist ein fünf Sterne System Betrug. Ja. Eigentlich ist es drei, drei Sterne, also du gibst mindestens zwei, maximal vier, wenn du wirklich etwas bewerten willst und es ernst meinst, mindestens zwei, maximal drei, äh, maximal vier Sterne. Das heißt, eigentlich pendelt sich dazwischen ein. Deswegen funktionieren fünf Sterne-Bewertungen nicht. Das wird nämlich auch so gedämmert, dass Leute, die eine Sterne geben oder fünf Sterne, die kannst du nicht ernst nehmen. Der eine ist übertrieben euphorisch, der andere ist sauer. Und meistens sind die einen Sterne-Bewertungen ja auch sowas wie, da kam ein Teil nicht mit, bei Amazon zum Beispiel oder so, Montagsmodell. Bei Fünfsterne ist meistens sowas wie, oh, das habe ich seit Jahren gesucht, aber man ist ja meistens nicht Teil dieser Gruppen. Eigentlich macht es keinen Sinn. Das ist auch die Amazon-Bewertung, so Fünfsterne war sehr schnell da. Und du denkst dir, ich habe nicht wenig Ahnung von Logistik und so, aber das kann doch nicht mit dem Produkt zusammenhängen. Also es kann doch nicht sein, dass manche, also bestimmt, keine Ahnung, die Firma, die dahinter steht, hat bessere Organisationen und sowas. Aber das hat nichts mit dem Produkt zu tun. Und vor allem, ich bestelle es ja auch nicht, weil ich mir denke, das ist schnell da. Vor allem, wenn es Produkte sind, wenn es jetzt, keine Ahnung, eine Bandage ist, so du blutest und bestellst hier Pflaster, dann willst du es schnell haben. Oder bei Tiertransporten. Aber halt so ein, keine Ahnung, so ein Buch oder so ein Zaun. Ja, bei zehn zum Beispiel wäre es auch besser. Zähnen. Zehn. Bei zehn Sternen wäre ich schon zufrieden. Wir haben Nachrichten bekommen. Haben, ach so. Und zwar möchte ich eine Nachricht aus unserer Medizin-Community vorlesen, und zwar hat uns jemand aufgeklärt zum Thema Fachbegriffe von Medizinern, wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, dass Mediziner bestimmt Begriffe haben für, ich habe keine Ahnung, was es sein soll, und deswegen benutze ich das. Und hier hat uns jemand geschrieben, der studiert anscheinend Medizin und der meint, der Begriff für keine Ahnung warum heisst idiopathisch.
Ja, idiopathisch. Also wenn ihr da stehen seht, irgendwie idiopathische Erkrankungen, idiopathische Fraktur, was auch immer, heißt es, ihr habt keine Ahnung, woher das kommt, was das soll. Keinen Schimmer. Was ich auch noch super interessant finde, ist, es gibt noch einen weiteren Begriff, und der heißt Iatrogen, Iatrogen,rogen und der bedeutet vom Arzt verursacht. Also wenn du da drauf schreibst, iatrogene Blutung, heißt es der Arzt selber, hat das verursacht. Wie deine Ärztin, die den einen C ausgewiesen hat. Genau, die musste dann iatrogene Fraktur des Cs und dann weiß der Arzt, der dann den Patienten übernimmt, oh da hat mein Kollege Scheiße gebraucht. Aber wahrscheinlich ist er auch dann diskret genug, den nicht in die Pfanne zu hauen. Warum reicht nicht ein Sorry? Ja, weil der Patient darf es ja nicht mitkriegen, sonst verliert er das Vertrauen in die Medizin an sich. Und er ist halt also durch den Arzt oder durch die Therapie hervorgerufen. Also es ist dann auch iirtrogenes Trauma oder so, ist während der Therapie entstanden. Wir haben ihn traumatisiert ausgesehen. Ja, aber es finde ich faszinierend. Und ja, ganz kurz, um das abzuschließen, ich habe meinen Fuß verloren, also meinen Schuh verloren. Ganz kurz neu formulieren. Du hast deinen Fuß verloren. Ich muss meinen Vorderfuß-Entlastungsschuh nicht mehr tragen und ich habe mich selten besser gefühlt. Ich tanze, ich gleite, ich schwebe durch die Stadt. Es ist herrlich, ich habe nicht mehr diesen Klotz am Bein. Es gab einen kurzen Moment, wo man sich denkt, okay, wir laufen, wie ging das nochmal? Aber ich kam relativ schnell rein und es fühlt sich gut an. Ja, der Vorderfuß muss sich erstmal wieder daran gewöhnen, belastet zu werden. Ja, der ist sehr belastet gerade. Bist du überbelastet. Aber es ist herrlich. Du musst dir ein bisschen gut zureden. Es ist herrlich. Aber wie schön ist es, ich fühle mich so elegant. Ich fühle mich so zart. Aber einer Schuhe ist jetzt deutlich ausgelatschter. Ja, das stimmt. Und auch ein Fuß ist kaputter. Das ist das Interessante, dass Schuhe immer gleich kaputt gehen, weil die halt immer gleich tragen werden. Bei dir ist es blöd, weil ein Schuh jetzt deutlich mehr gelaufen Meter auf der Sohle hat als der andere. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Da muss ich eh bald austauschen. Aber es ist, man fühlt sich so wie eine Gazelle, die tanzt durch die Welt, weil davor war man so diese klumpige Klotz, Klotz. Du weißt jetzt erst, was du kannst, wenn du dich mal verloren hast, die Fähigkeit auf jeden Fall. Das ist, schon mal, das ist doch herrlich. Wir haben grosse, grosse Neuigkeiten, wir freuen uns sehr, euch mitteilen zu dürfen, dass es weitergeht. Florentin, du kannst jetzt nicht trinken. Das sind die grossen Neuigkeiten für die Folge. Das sind die Neuigkeiten. Florentin und ich, wir gehen gemeinsam auf Tour. Es ist wieder so weit. Die grosse Das-Podcast-Ufo-Live-Tour 2020.
Wir freuen uns sehr.
Es sind diesmal fünf Termine an fünf fantastischen Orten.
Das ist ein bisschen grösser als letztes Mal.
Wir freuen uns sehr.
Die Termine sind, schnappt euch kurz einen Zettel und stift.
Wir warten nicht so lange.
Also Live-Podcast, so wie die letzten beiden Touren im Grunde auch.
Eigentlich so wie die letzten Mal auch.
Im Grunde hat sich nichts verändert. Aber es wird vielleicht ein bisschen besser. Wer die ersten Shows verpasst hat, kann jetzt kommen. Können Sie sich nicht mehr so ein, was Sie nicht mehr so ein, was Sie nicht mehr so ein, was Sie nicht mehr so ein, was Sie nicht mehr so ein ich will hier keinen einzigen weiteren Cent ausgehen. Das T-Shirt war eh schon so verdammt teuer. Ihr habt bestimmt jetzt genug Zeit gehabt, einen Stift zu holen. Ihr könnt kommen und unsuchen. Am 9.12. in Stuttgart, am 21.1. in Hamburg, am 28.2. in Berlin, am 19.4. in Mainz. Weiß ich noch nie. Und am 26.5. sind wir in Köln im E-Werk, großer Abschluss. Es sind ein bisschen größere Locations, gibt ein paar mehr Karten für die einzelnen Shows,
sind ein paar mal weniger Shows,
aber wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall sehr.
Ich glaube, da ist für jeden was dabei.
Die Frage, die ihr jetzt natürlich habt, ist, wann geht der Kartenvorverkauf los?
Völlig richtig,
morgen um 11 Uhr.
Also am Freitag.
Morgen ist Freitag, wenn ihr die Folge am Erscheinungsdatum hört, Donnerstag. Morgen um 11 Uhr, das ist der kommende Freitag. Ja, Freitag 11 Uhr, in der Woche, in der es erscheint, kriegt ihr das schon hin, oder? Man muss es nicht mit Daten um sich schmeißen. Ja, es wird großartig, wir freuen uns wieder drauf, fünf weitere Termine in ganz Deutschland. Schade, dass kein Abstecher nach Österreich diesmal drin ist, hat viel Spaß gemacht, aber vielleicht dann beim nächsten Mal. Ich hoffe, es ist für jeden was dabei und kommt vorbei, es gibt wieder fantastische Dinge zu erleben mit Stefan und mir. Was denn zum Beispiel so? Naja, wir stehen auf einer Bühne und erzählen das, was wir sonst auch erzählen würden. Ah ja. Aber halt mit besserem Licht. Das ist eine Stockdumpe wie hier. Und Akustik ist super. Akustik ist top und natürlich die Playlist ist wieder mit dabei. Freut euch darauf. Noch besser. Vorprogramm ist dabei. Ja. Echt? Na ja, die Playlist. Ach so. Ich weiß nicht. Kommt rum und schüttelt Stefan Tietze die Haare und freut euch darauf, ihn mal live sehen zu können. Ja, ich freue mich auch
sehr auf euch, euch alle mal in den Arm zu nehmen.
Ihr freut euch jetzt auf eine entspannte
nächste Woche. Ja, noch habt eine schöne Woche, habt eine gute Zeit.
Geht mal raus, geht mal rein, macht was ihr wollt.
Mir ist scheissegal. Wie gesagt, hört auf
keine Ratschläge, gebt keine Ratschläge, habt keine
Meinung und euch geht's besser.
Wir heben ab, macht's gut. Bis dann.
Ciao.